I'm experiencing the growing realization
that Donald Trump is likely going to be
the most thin-skinned president we've
maybe ever had and we saw this with the
Hamilton Mike Pence example where the
cast of the play Hamilton had a message
for Mike Pence that was incredibly
respectful and Donald Trump going on a
Twitter tirade talking about how safe
spaces must be enforced in movie in a
Broadway theaters etc another example is
the constant tweeting about Donald Trump
clearly being triggered by Saturday
Night Live and specifically Alec
Baldwin's impression of Trump Trump
actually tweeted after Alec Baldwin
again did that great impression over the
weekend just tried watching Saturday
Night Live unwatchable totally biased
not funny
and the Baldwin impersonation just can't
get any worse sad
well Alec Baldwin has now responded also
on Twitter which I guess is going to be
the official communications platform of
the incoming presidency by offering to
stop the aggressions if Donald Trump
will do something what is that thing
real Donald Trump release your tax
returns and I'll stop hah Trump in
October blasted Saturday Night Live's
presidential debates get as a quote hit
job I know this is sort of a silly thing
and not big big news in and of itself
Trump doesn't like Alec Baldwin's
impression of them but it's important
because it is yet another way in which
Donald Trump is not really the free
speech guy jail or losing citizenship
for burning flags is something Trump
suggested last week that is not a pro
free speech position particularly when
flag burning has been constitutionally
protected it is a constitutionally
protected action as confirmed by the
Supreme Court on numerous occasions no
understanding or sensibility for satire
from Donald Trump wants to strengthen
the ability to sue media outlets for
libel this is the level where politics
is operating in our country right now
it's shameful and especially Pat when
you consider that Trump is too busy for
intelligence briefings I told you last
week Trump has been turning a
whay president-elect intelligence
briefings in record numbers he's have he
has plenty of time to tweet about
satirical programs this is very
concerning well I'm also just glad that
all Alec Baldwin and others are
continuing to press them even after the
election about releasing his tax returns
yeah because at some point over his
presidency the audit by the IRS is going
to be up so we're gonna have no lame
excuses left yeah I like that you're
you're assuming we're ever gonna hear
about those audits again from Donald
Trump as if that wasn't just an excuse
to not release the tax returns I'm sure
in 2017 Trump's gonna say hey everybody
the audits are done here have my tax
returns that is not going to happen well
he's gonna have to come up with some
more even lamer excuse and I think
that's the point he'll say I'm not
running for anything why do I need to
release my tax returns I wonder if Alec
Baldwin is happy that now he can do the
Trump character for the next four years
at least or if he wanted to put the
entire thing to bed I have no idea if I
would want this to continue Pat or if
I'd want it to end I mean there's other
people at SNL who could take over and do
just as good of a Donald Trump
impression as far as the taxes are
concerned Trump can take the
embarrassment of SNL clearly
begrudgingly right under protest he'll
accept that this is probably going to
continue but clearly whatever is in
those tax returns is just too unbearable
for Donald Trump to give it up he would
much rather continue dealing with and
tweeting about the Alec Baldwin Trump
impression which I find to be good I
don't actually think it's great I think
it's funny I think the material is good
like what he says is good but I don't I
don't think it's if I had to rank this
as far as an impression I don't give it
a 10 I think I give it about a seven
hundred seven and a half yeah I think
it's decent the actor who played Trump
before Alec Baldwin came around I think
was a little bit better I don't know who
that was do you know yeah I'm not sure
all right so anyway Trump clearly going
to be the most thin-skinned president
likely in the history of the United
States at least in the modern era
certainly in the last hundred years
today's program is made possible in part
by blue apron I've talked before about
some of the the meals I've cooked with
blue apron this week I actually had a
really really great tigrin coconut curry
with sweet potato and jasmine rice which
I cooked myself and
the for me the greatest thing about blue
apron there's really two great things
number one it's if I depend on my own
creativity for cooking dinners by the
time it actually gets to the day to go
grocery shopping I basically go back to
like the eight or nine dishes that I
regularly cook so variety is not exactly
my strong suit when I'm picking meals so
it's great that blue apron actually has
a rotating menu they don't repeat
recipes at all within the year and
number two I hate food waste and I've
talked about this so many times before
when we look at how much food is just
thrown out and this includes before it
even gets to supermarkets by grocery
stores by individuals who buy too much
or forget they had X or Y ingredient
left in their fridge
blue apron gives you the exact amount of
each ingredient that you need for the
recipes and you completely eliminate
food waste and I really like that and
for less than ten bucks per meal you'll
get seasonal recipes pre-portioned
ingredients and it really is great also
on the menu this month brown butter and
chestnut gnocchi with Brussels sprouts
and pea shoot salad and you can check
out the entire menu and get three free
meals and free shipping on those meals
at blue apron dot-com slash Pakman
that's blue apron comm slash PA que ma n